شارك عدد من الوزراء في حكومه نتنياهو
يتقدمهم وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
فيما يعرف بمسيره الاعلام الاسرائيليه في
القدس واثارت المسيره والمشاركه الحكوميه
فيها ردود فعل غاضبه بين الفلسطينيين وعلى
المستويين الاقليمي والدولي اذ حملت قوه
فلسطينيه حكومه نتنياهو مسؤوليه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي الرسائل التي
تطلقها مجددا حكومه اليمين المتطرف في
اسرائيل بمشاركه وزراء فيها واعضاء كنيسه
الحاليين وسابقين في اقتحام الاقصى
المبارك تمهيدا لانطلاق مسيره الاعلام هل
هي رعايه رسميه
وكذلك ما هي احتمالات انزلاق الاوضاع الى
مواجهات في القدس والمدن الفلسطينيه بعد
تحذيرات الرئاسه الفلسطينيه من تفجر
الاوضاع وتحميل الفصائل حكومه الاحتلال
المسؤوليه عن الاعتداءات على الاماكن
المقدسه كذلك كيف يبدو الموقف الامريكي
ومواقف المجتمع الدولي من المشهد الراهن
في القدس وما مدى حرص واشنطن على الحيلوله
دون المس بالمقدسات وحفظ الاستقرار في
المنطقه عبر نداءاتها المتكرره في هذا
الشان
[موسيقى]
في نسختها الجديده لهذه السنه وبعيد موجه
العنف بين الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين شهدت
مسيره الاعلام الاسرائيليه التي تنطلق من
القدس الغربيه لتنتهي عند حائط البراق
شهدت مشاركه حكوميه رسميه واسعه المشاركه
شملت وزراء
واعضاء في الكنيست من اللكود واحزاب
الصهيونيه الدينيه الذين شاركوا جميعهم في
مسيره الاعلام بالقدس المسيره لم يغب عنها
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي اتمار اضافه
الى وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي
يشارك في مسيره الاعلام في القدس اجواء
يمنيه متطرفه وجد مستوطنون فيها فرصه لرفع
علم حركه كهان المحظوره دوليا والمصنفه
منظمه ارهابيه
في ظل ردود الفعل الفلسطينيه الغاضمه قامت
الشرطه الفلسطينيه او بالاحرى الشرطه
الاسرائيليه
والامن الاسرائيلي بتفريق عشرات
الفلسطينيين بالقوه وسط القدس المحتله بعد
رفعهم العلم الفلسطيني ومع التحذيرات
اقليميه ودوليه من الانزلاق مجددا الى
العنف قالت الامم المتحده ان المنسقه
الاممي يتواصل مع المعنيين بمسيره الاعلام
في القدس داعيا لضبط النفس وتجنب
الاستفزاز
[موسيقى]
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من رام الله
الدكتور علي الجرباوي استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه بيرزيت ومعنا من تكساس
رايان بول محلل لشؤون الشرق الاوسط في
مركز
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه اهلا بكما ابدا معك
اذا مسيره للاعلام جديده ولكن بمشاركه
رسميه هذه المره وبعد موجه عنف داميه ما
هي الرسائل التي تطلقها
تخبرنا بامور كثيره نعرفها من قبل لكن هذه
حكومه اسرائيليه يمينيه
اهمها وهدفها هو ضم المستوطنات وطبعا كنا
نعلم انهم سيسيرون هذه المسيره مسيره
الاعلام عبر المناطق الفلسطينيه دعما
لفكره ضم المستوطنات
وضد وجهه النظر الامريكيه وضد ايضا
المطالب الدبلوماسيه الدوليه دكتور علي في
النهايه يعني هذه المشاركه الرسميه
كيف نقراها كما وكيفن خصوصا انها تصدر من
حكومه تخوض معارك داخليه ومعارك طبعا
عنيفه جدا مع الفلسطينيين كالمعتاد
يعني اسرائيل مقسمه اسرائيل هي دولتين
الحقيقه دوله للمستوطنين ودوله اسرائيل في
حدود 48 وما شاهدناه اليوم ونشاهده كل يوم
هو ما تقوم به دوله المستوطنين من افعال
داخل ارض المحتله في القدس في القدس وفي
الضفه الغربيه من اجل ضمان ضم اكبر كميه
ممكنه من الارض
لاسرائيل فرض
السيطره والقانون الاسرائيلي على
المستوطنات وبالتالي ضمها فعليا لا يصير
ولكن هذه
المظاهره هي مظاهره اثبات وجود بمعنى ان
يعني امرنا شفنا احنا في اي محل في الدنيا
ناس لهم
السياده بطلعوا على عاصمتهم بيحملوا اعلام
وبيقولوا هاي عاصم الابديه
اسرائيل حاولت او قامت بالضم للقدس في عام
67 يعني من 56 عام قامت بضم من قبل
الحكومه بتفويض من الكنيست ثم بعد عشر
سنوات الكنيست اتخذ قرار بالضم الفعلي
وحتى الان القدس ليس لاسرائيل السياده
عليها القدس الشرقيه القدس الشرقيه هي
عربيه بامتياز مع كل المحاولات التي تقوم
بها اسرائيل عبر الحكومات المتتاليه من ال
67 ليس فقط هذه الحكومه اليمينيه وانما من
حكومات حزب العمل وصولا الى اليوتيوب حتى
اليوم هذه حكومات قامت بمحاوله شرسه لفرض
السيطره على القدس حققت الكثير من يعني
الاستيطان حول المدينه ولكن المدينه
القديمه البلده القديمه في القدس لا زالت
عربيه بامتياز
ولذلك هم يح ان يظهروا بان لهم سياده يعني
مظاهره لمده يوم يرفع فيها اعلام بيقولوا
هاي القدس لنا هذا يعني لهم السياده عليها
مش ضروري يرفعوا اعلام ويطلعوا في مظاهره
مشان يقولوا لنا انه هاي القدس
ولكن رغم ذلك كانوا يشعرون بان هناك حاجه
لرعايه رسميه سيد راين بول ان يكون هناك
وجود رسمي لهذه المسيره وفي النهايه
السؤال هو على ماذا تراهن الحكومه نتنياهو
وهي تعرف اكثر من غيرها طبعا ما يمكن ان
تقود اليه
حاليا تريد ان تبقي على
القوه اليمين المتطرف في الكنيست ورايناهم
كيف يستعرضون عضلاتهم يهددون باسقاط
الحكومه
بنينه الماهو هو كرئيس وزراء اضعف مما كان
عليه في السابق ويحاول التشبث بسلطته
وطبعا هم لديهم نظره اكثر وضوحا حول القدس
والقص الشرقيه باعتبارها عاصبه لهم وهم
ومنذ اربع سنوات يحاولون ارسال رسائل
رمزيه الى الفلسطينيين
المجتمع الدولي بانهم يغيرون الحقائق على
الارض هو جزء من اهدافه مسيره الاعلام
لفرض السياده الاسرائيليه على هذه المنطقه
وتعزيز ما يعتقدون انهم قد حققوه وهم طبعا
هم
قالوا ان القدس عاصمه لهم من دون رد فعل
دولي كبير والان يريدون تعزيز موقفهم هذا
هذه الرسائل دكتور علي الجرباوي التي
ترسلها هذه الحكومه كيف تقارن برسائل كانت
ترسلها حكومه سابقه
يعني كل الحكومات كما ذكرت لك حاولت
وتحاول يعني تثبيت
وجودها في القدس تحديدا يعني لذلك لم
يتوقف حركه الاستيطان والاستيلاء على
المنازل يعني والعنف ضد المقدسيين لم
يتوقف للحظه
ولكن هذه حكومه هي برسم السقوط لاننا
نتنياهو يرتعد قلقا من يعني المتطرفين
اليمينيين الذين يهددونه صباح مساء
بالخروج واسقاطه وهذه اخر مره سيكون فيها
رئيس الحكومه على ما يبدو لذلك هو متشبث
بوجود هذه الحكومه ولذلك هو اسير ايضا
لهذه التيارات اليمينيه التي تريد ان او
تحاول ان تفرض واقع جديد بسرعه كبيره من
اجل انهاء الموضوع يعني بدل اداره الصراع
هم يريدون
الصراع بضم اكبر كميه من الارض ممكنه
لاسرائيل اثناء وجودهم بهذه الحكومه ولكن
يعني نجاح هذا المسعى ليس بالضروره ان
يكون مضمونا لانه هناك الكثير من الضغوطات
الداخليه والخارجيه الدوليه والاقليميه
على اسرائيل على هذه الحكومه التي لا تسمح
لها ان تقوم بما يريد اليمين المتطرف بدون
اي يعني حدود هم يحاولون ولكن يعني
المحاوله لن تكون يعني محسومه بالنجاح له
يعني الدكتور جرباوي كان يتحدث عن ان
نتنياهو يرتعد خوفا في هذه المرحله هل
توافق على ذلك يعني في ادنى الاحوال يمكن
ان نتكلم عن وضع هش خصوصا بعد الموجه
التصعيد الاخيره من جانب الاسرائيليين
هل ترى فعلا ان هناك بوادر
لزيت جديد يصب على نار مشتعله اصلا
ان هذا هو عمل سياسي محض وهو انقى انواع
التلاعبات السياسيه
نتنياهو يدرك انه ان لم يحسم هذه الجوله
سيخسر ائتلافه الحاكم ولن يجد شيئا يحميه
من تهم ومحاكمات الفساد التي يواجهها وفي
الوقت نفسه هو يخاطر مخاطره محسوبه فبعد
التصعيد ضد حركه الجهاد الاسلام في
الاسبوع الماضي والتي ادت الى مقتل عدد من
قاده الجهاد الاسلامي
نتنياهو يعتقد انه على الاقل حاليا قد ردع
الجهاز الاسلامي من التعرض لمسيره الاعلام
لهذا السبب نرى انه رغم تهديدات الجهاز
الاسلامي وحماس لم يطلق ايه صواريخ ضد
المسيره كما فعلوا في العمل 2022
ربما بسبب ما حدث في غزه في الاسبوع
الماضي
يعني بغض النظر عن الدكتور علي الجرباوي
السؤال
موجه لك بغض النظر عن اجنده نتنياهو فاذا
كان الهدف هو
الاستفزاز والتصعيد هل فعلا يعني يمكن ان
نقرا سيناريو جديد على ضوء موقف القوى
والفصائل الفلسطينيه هذه المره ما تعليقك
عليها يعني يعني
دائما هذه التصريحات تاتي بعد كل حادثه من
الاحداث يعني وفي اوقات كثيره يعني يكونوا
مجرد كلام ولكن ليس هذا هو الموضوع حقيقه
ليس هي التهديدات والشعارات انما هو الوضع
على الارض الوضع الارض يعني متفجر بدون
بدون كل هذا التهديد والكلام كل يوم كل
ليله هناك اقتحامات اس
لمخيمات وقرى ومدن الضفه هناك مواجهات
يوميه قد نسمع عنها وقد لا نسمع ولكن كل
يوم هناك مواجهات الوضع متفجر اصلا يعني
وليس بحاجه الى وكانه هادئ وهناك يعني
حاجه الى الوضع يعني يعني واصل لحدود
شديده يعني قبل كم يوم انتهى العدوان على
غزه والان الضفه تعود ويعني نتنياهو
سيتفاجى من الموقف الفلسطيني عندما تحدث
اول عمليه من الضفه هو حاول ما حاول في
قطاع غزه ليكبح جماح الضفه الغربيه ولكن
اول عمليه ستحدث وعلى فكره لم يكن
بالامكان دائما انه ان تواجه مسيره
الاعلام يعني بمقاومه فلسطينيه لها لان
القدس تفرغ وتغلق وتصبح سكنه عسكريه ولا
يسمح الفلسطينيين بالتحرك من اجل هذه
المسيره لذلك ما في امكانيه ان المسيره
نفسها ان ان تصاب ولكن التداعيات لذلك
سنشهدها لاحقا والوضع يعني على على الارض
هو متفجر اصلا
وستزداد الاوضاع تفاقما مع كل هذه
المحاولات الاسرائيليه هي ليس فقط يعني
مسيره الاعلام ولكن الاستفزازات من
المستوطنين اليوميه لكل فلسطيني موجود في
الضفه الغربيه وفي القدس ماذا عن الاداره
الامريكيه ما هو موقف الاداره الامريكيه
وهي ترى ما يجري على الارض وترى كم الغضب
الموجود لدى جانب الفلسطيني وما يمكن
اعتباره استفزاز واضح
وجريء يزداد قوه كل مره من الجانب
الاسرائيلي
الامريكيين بالتاكيد يعارضون اي اعمال
استفزازين كهذا لكن كل هذا يحدث على خلفيه
جو سياسيه اكبر الولايات المتحده تركز على
اوكرانيا وروسيا وعلى الصين وتايوان وفي
الشرق الاوسط تركز على ايران والى حد اقل
على حاله التقارب بين
ايران والسعوديه لهذا السبب القضيه
الفلسطيني لا تحتل مكان كبيره في اجنده
الاداره ولن يتجاوز موقفهم البيانات
العلنيه فلن يحاولوا فرض اي الضغوط ولا
لاي ذراع اي طرف في الحقيقه في الصراع
الذي شهدناه في غزه ام اعتمدوا مره اخرى
على اللاعبين الاقليميين مثل مصر وغيرها
للتوصل لوقف اطلاق النار اذا كان هناك اي
طرف ممكن يحد من التوتر سيكون من بين
اللاعبين
الاقليميين مثل مصر والاردن وقطر
والسعوديه وغيرها السيد كنت قد اشرت قبل
قليل الى وضع الاماكن المقدسه وهو امر تصر
الاداره الامريكيه انها تعتبره خطا احمر
وانها يعني ترفض اي مساس به ولكن فعليا
على الارض هل ترى اي شيء من ذلك يتحقق ما
الذي تفعله الاداره الامريكيه على الاقل
لكي تقنع
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين فعلا هي جاده
طبعا هم يلجاون الى الاردنيين عاده لارسال
رسائل بان وضع المسجد الاقصى
وجبل معبد لم يتغير وهم سوف يستمرون في
تعزيز رسالتهم وهم سوف يحاولون الضغط على
نتنياهو وبن غدير لكي يخففوا من هذا
التوتر بالوسائل الدبلوماسيه والوسائل
الدبلوماسيه هي التي يستخدمونها للحيلوله
دون التصعيد في المناطق المقدسه وما حولي
اياها
في النهايه
بن جبير قد يقرر الزياره او الدخول الى
الموقع المقدس هذه حتى بدون موافقه
نتنياهو وبدون اقتراس للضغوط الدبلوماسيه
هذه الضغوط الدبلوماسيه كما سمع السيد بول
علي هل ترى فعلا انها تقنع احدا
وخصوصا الفلسطينيين سواء على المستوى
الرسمي او المستوى الشعبي
وهل فعلا هناك اي قدر من التعويل من
الجانب الفلسطيني على مثل هذه الضغوط
يعني الاداره الامريكيه اداره لا اراده
لها لانها لو كان لديها الاراده لفعلت او
لاستطاعت ان تفعل شيئا ولكن لا اراده لهذه
الاداره
اذكر فقط بان الاحداث يعني هذه الاداره
عندما وصلت
البيت الابيض قالت بانها ستعيد فتح
القنصليه في القدس الشرقيه القنصليه
الامريكيه لم يكن هناك اوكرانيا ولا روسيا
ولا حرب ولا شيء من هذا القبيل ولكنها لم
تستطع يعني ولم تضغط حتى يعني هي قالت ولم
تضرب لذلك لا تعويل على هذه الاداره هذه
اداره ضعيفه الادارات الامريكيه منحازه
بالكامل واحده تلو الاخرى لاسرائيل هذه
اداره كمان يعني اشهر سيكون هناك بدايه
حمله انتخابيه بايدن سيخود يخوض
الانتخابات هو غير معني بان يقوم باي تحرك
يعني ضد اسرائيل او حتى يعني ان يقرع
اسرائيل لذلك البيانات تتوالى وهي نفس
الصيغه ونفس يعني كما قال
ضيفك انه هم يعولون على مصر وعلى الاردن
وعلى اللاعبين الاقليميين لتهدئه الاوضاع
واداره الصراع ليس هناك اي توجه لحل
الصلاح او كبح الاسراع هناك فقط اداره
للصراع وباقل تكاليف ممكنه من المجتمع
الدولي وخصوصا من الولايات المتحده
ما الذي يجعل الولايات المتحده
انشات يعني تمثل هذا الدور في المسرحيه
بمعنى ان
ها تتحدث بصرامه عن وجوب التخلص من وزراء
متطرفين وتخاطب المستوى الدولي على انها
يعني ضد هؤلاء من الذي يجعلها تقوم بهذا
الموقف وهي ليست مستعده على الاطلاق ان
تفعل شيء حقيقي يدعم هذا الكلام
المره الاخيره التي راينا فيها ضغطا مهما
على اسرائيل بسبب سياسات الخارجيه كان في
ظل اداره الزوج دبليو بوش قبل ثلاثين عاما
وعندما انتهت الحرب البارزه واصبح اصبحت
منطقه الشرق الاوسط منطقه
فيها اضطرابات وارادت ترتل المتحده ان
تفرض الامن فيها من دون قوه مناقضه من
الاتحاد السوفيتي لكن هم طبعا في نهايه
اتفاقات السلام في مدريد ان لم تمتثل
اسرائيل هددت بقطع المساعدات عنها لكن لا
شيء من هذا موجود اليوم طبعا اسرائيل تحظى
بدعم كبير في الكونجرس رغم ان ذلك بدا
يتغير وايضا هناك دوافع استراتيجيه
اسرائيل هي شريك استراتيجي في الحرب او في
ضد ايران وايضا اسرائيل تقدم الدعم
لاوكرانيا في حربها ضد روسيا هذه الامور
مهمه للبيت الابيض وهو لا يريد تعريضها
تعريض هذه الروابط الاستراتيجيه للخطر
بسبب
اسرائيل الفلسطيني وايضا
انتهى الوقت شكرا جزيلا لك
شؤون الشرق الاوسط في مركز ستفر للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه شكرا جزيلا للدكتور علي
الجرباوي استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
بيرست
وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا على متابعه هذه الحلقه
من برنامج نور الخبر في
[موسيقى]